[Musique]
15h50 vendredi 7 septembre pour javols
dans deux heures que aujourd'hui on a
mille ans étaient présents pour la
présentation du big band 3 2 chez au mit
et retours paris c'est très dur ce matin
c'est à dire parce que j'ai dormi une
heure j'ai bossé jusqu'à je sais pas
quelle heure je dormais juste une heure
j'ai pas pu dormir plus beaucoup trop
travail
la veille j'ai dormi à peine trois
heures et demie l'avant-veille 3h30
là ça devient petit peu rock'n roll mais
aujourd'hui on va parler de notre
smartphone
[Musique]
ça j'ai pas trouvé une tête de déterré
ça là franchement je suis frais je vous
parlais de mondes connectés hier avec la
nouvelle niveau 3 de chimie et justement
on va parler justement le monde connecté
parce que ça m'intéresse et que j'ai
reçu deux trois trucs
alors bon c'est un début de nous
rappeler notre a testé je vous montrais
l'autre jour j'avais reçu la tique watch
pro on va la tester on va regarder alors
on est vraiment sur autre chose on a
testé aussi la la masse fit la stratos
deux pas de bêtises il n'ya pas
longtemps on va regarder cette mi band 3
on va regarder à cette montre la
connecter au siècle le fitness tracker
avaya pas mal de choses de questions à
poser du point de vue des mondes
connectés
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
avec du coup à qui elle se destine
qu'est ce qu'on pourra faire demain avec
les mondes connectés c'est quoi l'avenir
des mondes connectés donc on va tester
ses produits individuellement possible
d'avoir une vision plus globale et ça
mon avis avait vraiment intéressant si
vous suivez la chaîne vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que quelques jours j'étais à
berlin là je rentre tout juste de milan
là il est quelque chose comme 11h55 qui
s'est décollé ce matin de milan à six
heures mais je voulais vous faire
voyager encore un petit peu on va
retourner à berlin où on était la
semaine dernière lors de l'ifa je vais
vous parler aujourd'hui d'acheter c'est
parce que htc nous a présenté un nouveau
smartphone c'est le htc u12 life c'est
un modèle milieu de gamme de chez htc
mais je trouve suffisamment intéressant
pour qu'on en parle
[Musique]
on se retrouve à berlin devant l'autel
zhu pourparlers d'htc pense que htc à
des nouveautés à nous montrer
aujourd'hui
alors là on s y trouvaient la cougar ou
la salle de conférence par là par là je
sais que des gens là parlent un peu que
les équipes de htc l'idée de htc laden
de htc c'est de faire des smartphones
qui ne ressemble pas aux autres
du coup sur ce smartphone pas d'encoches
indo différence qu'on peut retrouver un
chez ses concurrents il a des faux airs
du google pixels et au final c'est
plutôt pas mal si vous regardez le dos
vous et toute une partie sur le banc où
il ya des petites lignes des petites
stries le but d'avoir mis ça c'est de ne
pas laisser de traces de doigts alors
que la partie en haut où il ya le module
photo là effectivement pour l'été les
traces de doigts sauf que la logique de
htc et qui est vraiment très très juste
c'est de se dire là où vous allez le
prendre votre main c'est sur la partie
basse donc les traces de doigts au vous
vous en moquez par contre un bail en
aura pas en plus de ça ça lui donne
beaucoup de caractère c'est un design
assez atypique et pour coup c'est
vraiment intéressant et un aspect
métallique qui donne un côté assez
classieux vous retrouvez bien évidemment
un capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est plutôt bien placé paille en coloris
il est dispo en moonlight bleus c'est la
couleur principale mais également en
twilight purple qui en acier avec des
touches de violet hill et un écran
rectangulaire l'idée d'acheter ces c'est
de se dire qu'on regarde des vidéos au
format rectangulaire que globalement
tout ce qu'on va faire va est
rectangulaire donc on n'a pas besoin de
sept ans coche c'est vraiment un point
de différenciation par rapport à se
retrouver sur marche actuellement un
écran 6 pouces avec une définition de
2160 par 1080 pixels c'est donc du fhd
plus d'un écran lcd
c'est une dalle ltps qui occupent 83% de
la face avant
lorsque j'ai pris en main tester le
rendu des couleurs est vraiment bien les
contrastes sont ok même lorsque vous
êtes à l'extérieur il fait parfaitement
le job et du point de vue des caméras
vous avez un double module photo
l'arrière 16 mégapixels + 5 mégapixels
le 16 mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.0
tandis que le 5 mégapixels d'arthur de f
2.2 le 5 mégapixels vous servira pour
les faits évoqués pour le mode portrait
pourra vraiment un flou qui se détache
complètement naturel à l'arrière donc
effectivement là dessus on s'en moque un
peu d'avoir une bonne luminosité tout
filmé enquête qui en 30 images par
seconde ayant en effet hd en 60 images
par seconde à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 13 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f/2
zéro qui dans beaucoup de cas sera
franchement suffisamment lumineuse à
noter que vous avez un flash led pour
saïfi et bien évidemment du hdr est
maintenant sous le capot il tourne avec
un qualcomm snapdragon à 636 qui est 40%
plus puissant que le qualcomm snapdragon
634 giga de ram 64 giga de stockage et
il a une batterie de 3600 milliampères
heures htc nous dit qu'il peut aller
jusqu'à 13 heures de vidéos 88 heures de
musique et 12 heures de surf sur
internet
donc de ce point de vue là vous devriez
franchement être tranquille alors ce
dont je vous parle tout de suite c'est
une prise en main j'ai pu le voir dans
un hôtel on était vraiment en petit
comité j'ai pas fais des tests complets
peut-être qu'on aura un test
ultérieurement à ce moment là je pourrai
vraiment vous donner mon retour et vous
dire si il est bien en termes
d'autonomie oui ou non
en attendant ce qui a lancé par htc a
l'air quand même assez séduisant il a
des haut parleurs stéréo et last but not
least comme gérer les américains il ya
surtout une prise jack et ça c'est un
très bon point lille a dû s but il s'est
par contre il n'a pas de recharge rapide
donc falloir laisser un petit peu plus
de temps chargé par rapport à certains
autres modèles dans cette gamme de prix
il a du bluetooth 5.0 du nfc pour les
paiements dématérialisés soit une double
carte sim soit une carte sim et une
carte micro sd pour ajouter du stockage
et ce qui est intéressant en termes de
photos vidéos il a une stabilisation
logiciels e s il tourne sous android 8
points mais pour l'instant on n'a
absolument aucune information sur 1,9
greg sur android 9 paille et il est le
charmant score surtout 213 1040 et il
sera disposé 2 octobre au tarif de 345
euros
c'est un smartphone qui n'a pas de
certification ip67 mais htc nous a
assuré qu'il serait résistant aux
éclaboussures et à la poussière
je vous déconseille néanmoins d'aller
jeter dans internautes peuvent faire le
test
voilà pour les infos je voulais partager
avec vous sur ce htc u12 life moi ce que
j'ai vraiment apprécié sur ce modèle
c'est le design au niveau du dos il ya
un aspect un peu bi-matière avec les
rainures le côté sans rainures sur le
dessus je crois que c'est vraiment une
bonne idée que ça permette effectivement
de pallier aux traces de doigts
le parti-pris aussi du htc de ne pas
m'être d'encoches c'est plutôt bien pour
se différencier de ce qui se fait
actuellement sur le marché
ça peut séduire pas mal de monde et ça
pousse intéressant parce que si htc nous
avait sorti une
mon coach on se serait dit ça y est htc
prend le pli ils font la même chose que
les autres et leur modèle serait passé
un petit peu plus à travers le public
aura été plus indifférent et là ils vont
vraiment affirmer un caractère avec un
modèle qui est très sympa en termes de
performances
l'instinct dragonne 136 vous allez
pouvoir l'utiliser pour des applications
courantes de la vie quotidienne des
réseaux sociaux des emails navigation
regarder des vidéos netflix youtube
tout ce que vous voyez vous aura
absolument aucun problème quel que je
n'avais pas chercher des performances
hyper forte si vous allez sur déjà un
peu plus gourmand vous allez être un
petit peu limité c'est pas ce smartphone
qui va rendre le mieux dans cette gamme
de prix en tout cas vous vous situez
quand même sur les même prix qu'un honor
play ou un poco faut des fins donc bon
si vous cherchez de la performance c'est
pas nécessairement là dessus qu'il faut
aller j'ai un peu peur que ce soit
compliqué pour acheter c'est parce que
même si ce modèle est séduisant même si
les jolies je vous le dit dans le milieu
de gamme
vous avez des mastodontes et notamment
avec le poke open f1 qu'on l'a testée ya
pas très longtemps et même l'honneur
planes qui est vraiment très bonne
facture
j'ai peur que ce soit un peu compliqué
pour eux de faire leur chemin à moins
qu'il y ait des amoureux vraiment du
modèle des amoureux de la marque sinon
par rapport à la concurrence
j'ai des doutes tout dit il fait 345
euros vous trouvez le honor plaît à 329
euros et peugeot phone à 329 euros
il est donc plus cher que des
smartphones bien plus performant que lui
j'ai peur que ce soit un peu compliqué
pour eux c'est sur ce coup dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter par ce
smartphone est ce que vous le trouvez
couler ce que vous trouvez que htc va
dans le bon sens et surtout qu'est ce
que vous pensez de design parce qu'à mon
avis si on veut aller sur ce smartphone
c'est que le design vous tente
réellement c'est qu'il ya un vrai parti
pris que vous aimez et que vous vous en
fichez au final d'avoir de la
performance d'avoir un sens dragone 845
inquiries 970 bon un petit peu dites moi
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire sur
ce je vous laisse bien je fais des
bécaud et je vous dis à demain un foyer
au rendez vous
[Musique]